reunión de los jefes de estado de la
unión africana comenzó esta mañana con
20 minutos de retraso hace apenas unos
minutos casi todos los presidentes del
continente han pasado por este pasillo
para llegar a la sala de conferencia
Nelson Mandela así pues aunque hoy sea
el día más importante de la Cumbre
porque se
harán muchos anuncios no debemos olvidar
que los jefes de estado están en la
décima desde ayer y han realizado muchas
reuniones bilaterales en estas primeras
reuniones dominó el tema de la
inseguridad por ejemplo veo mareñón
sobre la situación del conflicto en el
este de la República democrática del
Congo que resultó en una decisión
importante la exigencia por parte de la
unión africana de La retirada de los
grupos armados de la región del cubo
antes del día 30 de marzo estamos solo
al principio de esta primera jornada que
estará con muchos anuncios en particular
sobre la cuestión de la puesta en marcha
del proyecto de zona africana de libre
comercio